Take a look at these columns of text.
Some of you may be able to read
all of the columns and for
some of you, it might be a little
difficult or frustrating,
especially as we get further
over to the right here.
And what you're looking at is
a range of of contrasts and
above each column, I've placed a
contrast ratio which is the relationship
between the foreground color and the
background color in terms of luminance.
When the colors are very similar,
we have a low contrast ratio.
When the colors are very different
we get a high contrast ratio.
In section 1.4.3 the web link
checklist recommends a minimum
contrast ratio of 4.5 to 1 for
all body text and images.
An exception is made for
a larger text text that's about 120 or
150% larger than the default body copy.
For that larger text the ratio
can go down to 3 to 1.
And the contrast ratio of 4.5
to 1 was chosen as a minimum,
because it compensates for
the loss in contrast sensitivity,
usually experienced by users with 20/40
vision and 20/40 vision is commonly
reported as the typical visual acuity
for someone of around 80 years of age.
So, looking at our columns of text,
we can see that really only these
first two columns would pass for
acceptable body copy.
The third one here is just a little
too low on the contrast scale, and
this last one is far too light.
Now I mention that these
are contrast minimums.
So while they might work well for
someone who has lost a bit of vision as
they age they will not necessarily work
well for all users, especially those who
suffer from a low vision impairment.
For users with low vision impairments,
or color vision deficiencies
we can increase the contrast
up to a ratio of 7 to 1 for
body copy and 4.5 to 1 for larger text.
Looking again at our
columns we can see that,
really only this first column
would meet that criteria.
Now since most modern web sites
use a range of type sizes and
colors, you're going to need a way
to quickly audit your page to
verify that you're meeting
these contrasts requirements.
To do this we can use the Chrome
accessibility dev tools extension.
So what I want to do is audit this page,
I'm going to open my dev tools,
I'm going to go to the Audits panel and
I'll run an accessibility audit.
And I can see that the extension is
reporting a number of accessibility
errors all related to my anchor tags.
So let me go inspect one of those anchor
tags right now, click on this one
right over I'll bump the font size up
a little bit so this is easier to read.
And when I go and
look at the accessibility properties for
this item I'm presented with
a number of options here.
First I see a warning indicating
that my contrast is just too low.
And then I see options for
minimum and enhanced contrast.
Now the nice thing is that
the hex values are right here so
I can just copy these into
my style sheet if I want.
But one really cool feature of
the dev tools extension is that I can
click on the swatches and see
the anchor tags update in the document.
So I can see here for instance that that
is what the enhanced colors would look
like in my application.
Now, in the next lesson,
I'm going to have you audit
a page using the same extension.
So that way,
you can fix up any errors that you find.